Vsauce hello Michael here and an IMG 12
I showed you some Kinect fails but today
I want to explore my favorite Kinect
wins the Kinect tracks 20 joints on your
body 30 times a second and with simple
drivers people from all over the world
are taking it into their own hands
besides exploiting the fact that it's an
actual 3d camera people are harnessing
it to play all sorts of games with their
hands in the air like they just don't
care for example Minecraft Mario Kart
Super Mario Brothers or this guy who
made a demo of 3d Tetris where your
hands manipulate the pieces and you can
move your head to change the screens
perspective a few days ago Kevin showed
you a guy who used the Kinect emotion
track his nipples and cover them up well
if you're less shy do what this guy did
program your Kinect to recognize and
reify your air guitar it's like playing
rock band but without all the plastic
paraphernalia this guy let it detect his
body but then replace it with the back
wall to make him the Invisible Man
creepy right well not as creepy as this
here's someone who took the connects
recognition of his body and had it
transformed him in real time to a giant
pillowy blob mutant in case you're
curious yes he did make a follow-up
video with his cat but why not mount the
Kinect on a robot and use it as the
robots eyes well these people did and
since the Kinect sees in 3d of course
it's a flying robot question what if the
Star Wars kid was not only a dork but
also a geek
answer he may have done what this guy
did use the Kinect to track a wooden
stick and give it a lightsaber overlay
or if you prefer Christmas lights check
out this girl who can control lights
like a conductor by waving her hands to
see more of these and other kinect hacks
or to get pointers on how to experiment
yourself check out kinect hacks net or
follow the links in this video's
description where links to everything I
covered can be found oh oh and and let
me know in the comments below what year
you think it will be when our brains are
completely replaced by computers 2070
3015 or are you one of those crazy
people on the street who think it
already happened well either way I want
to know
leave it in the comments and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]